now you're you know famous and Infamous
for so many reasons all you know fun and
interesting and the table flip is no
exception
um you know in the first season of The
Housewives I mean it's been a long time
you've been on there
um season 13's coming out yes
okay so what is like one of the favorite
things that's ever happened to you from
your life changing from being a
housewife
um I was just on Dancing With the Stars
[Applause]
listen I always wanted to dance like my
whole life and
um I'm not that flexible or anything
like that but it was like a dream that I
always had and I'm glad I got to do it
so that was like a big fulfillment
um being a four times New York Times
best-selling author that's a that's a
big fulfillment yeah four cookbooks two
Memoirs and I also like that you flip
tables because I also I told you I got
that angel and that devil on each
shoulder I'm trying to work on myself
because everyone thinks I'm like this
mean person from being on the show I'm
like I'm so not I'm like listen to my
podcast Namaste you'll get to
know the real Teresa that's right and
I'm so I'm so easy going and I'm like
such a you know well like I'm just I go
with the flow I like to have fun that
show is also going for the big moment
yeah I figured you know I don't think
they would love you sitting around being
a nice quiet person yeah that's not what
the show is all right can you please I
have to show a clip your table flip from
the first season because this is an
iconic moment okay
[Applause]
thank you
Teresa
I mean I love you I get that I like a
good drink in the face too that's a real
clutch move I know have you ever done
that no you're missing
and do it all right will you walk me
through what happened there yes so okay
well um think about something that makes
you really really angry like you know if
your boyfriend cheated on you or um like
if if a girlfriend betrayed you yeah
some like that because that she wasn't
going after my girlfriend so I was
sticking up for my girlfriend oh yeah so
I'm a girl's girl oh yeah so just think
about something that makes you really
angry and then grab the table okay right
and hold on to it yeah and then right
now at the count of three all right
ready one one two three
[Applause]
thank you thank you thank you sorry
I do
thank you
thank you oh my god Jersey airs Tuesdays
on Broadway and be sure to check her out
on her awesome new podcast Namaste
all right up next it's pop week
spot quiz week and someone might win
over a thousand dollars worth of jewelry
I don't know come back we'll see what
happens
[Applause]
[Music]